[Musique]
enthousiaste à la tâche et collégiens de
saint louis enquête sur l'histoire des
cyclones à la réunion un phénomène
naturel qui fait partie de nos vies
siens là c'est le cyclone gamède c'est
là-bas 2007
kiki b qui a marqué parce que ben moi je
tends corps petit ma maman elle l'a
vécue et apparemment ben c'était c'est
un gros cyclone et que ben déjà payé la
détruire le pont de la rivière
saint-étienne
j'ai appris comment se protéger quand il
y aura un cyclone parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu une salle de
lecture des archives départementales où
se trouve des trésors de savoir et avec
les trésors les précautions sont de mise
respect des documents donc manipuler dès
que les cat man les documents ne pas
toucher les documents ne pas écrire sur
les documents et ne pas s'appuyer sur
les documents donc ça c'est important
donc toujours mettre les documents
devant et donc c'est quand même des
documents précieux important que
l'histoire de la réunion et les enfants
doivent aussi connaître aida comment
manipuler ces documents des lettres du
papier jauni des journaux des photos sur
papier à l'heure du numérique
ces supports d'apprentissage deviennent
innovant acquérir des connaissances et
développer des compétences dans
différents domaines donc aussi bien dans
le domaine scientifique où on a pu
apprendre ce qu'était réellement un
cyclone où il se forme et les conditions
de formation dans le domaine de la
maîtrise de la langue dont qui est
vraiment la base surtout pour des élèves
de réseau d'éducation prioritaire et ça
leur permet aussi de développer des
compétences dans le domaine numérique
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
très riche avant d admiration l'afd
vidéos des interviews en fait vraiment
utile
on a commencé cette annexe
merci de vous être engagé dans cette
dans cette démarche alors nous on a la
mémoire de cyclone depuis l'origine le
cyclone ont été enregistrés à l'île de
la réunion depuis seize 157 avant même
le peuplement et nous on a la trace dès
le début du xviiie des dégâts qui sont
causés ici ou à l'île de france à
travers la correspondance des
administrateurs la compagnie des indes
une thématique qui est alors levier
pédagogique mais surtout un moyen de
transmission d'une culture commune celle
du risque il faut connaître le
territoire dans lequel on vit les
risques encourus par ce territoire et
c'est ce qui fait la force d'une
population sur un territoire donné c'est
de vivre en prenant en compte les
risques et ça passe par cette cette
culture là alors qu'il n'y a pas eu de
cyclone depuis 2002 sur notre île
préserver la mémoire devient essentiel
surtout qu'il est impossible d'éviter le
passage d'un météore
[Musique]